if you want to bet on the future of
humanity and where a lot of growth is
going to come from investing in
technology is the way to do it
yeah
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right this is one of the best
episodes i think we've done in a long
time i'm going to tell you everything
that we talked about but first spotify
just has this like new feature i want to
see how great it is so basically if
you're on spotify
go to
pull the app up look at it look at our
my first million page and you're going
to see a little bell do me a favor hit
that bell i want to see if you'll be
notified when we have our next episode i
want to see if this thing works if it
does work sign up click the bell and
then tweet at me tell me if it works and
i'll like give you a retweet or
something like that in exchange for
clicking it but click that for me and
let me know if it works so today's
episode i think is one of the best
episodes we've done in a very very long
time we talk about the amazon
liquidation business i'm actually going
to record myself buying from one of
these websites it's a fascinating
business where they sell you a bunch of
return stuff but it's packed in a
mystery package we talk about fake data
there's this new company called tonic
that's selling fake data to help you
test your stuff crazy fascinating
business and then my favorite topic is
this guy called harold alphon he's the
billy of the week this amazing
billionaire that started a shoe company
and eventually gave away most of his
money but incredibly fascinating we
talked about a few other stuff like like
how tiger global's making all this money
in the future of vc that's pretty
fascinating but my favorite part was the
billy of the week check it out and by
the way on your phone you're probably
listening to this on your phone go to
spotify click that bell i think they
just released this recently someone was
telling me about it tell me if you get
notified like send like a like click the
bell and then just send me a screenshot
when the next episode comes out and tell
me if it works the sampar on twitter i
wanna know if this works i'll retweet
you if you um send it to me all right
enjoy the episode okay so what did you
think about the remit episode
i thought it was pretty good i thought
he does a good job like
i guess i always break it up into two
categories
how how interesting is the stuff you're
saying and then how interesting are you
at saying it so he was like i thought he
was very interesting in how he says
things like he bri he brings energy
he
is not afraid to like
call something stupid like you know he
brings a little bit of that flair that
you need for something to be fun
um in terms of the info
i thought it was pretty good i think um
yeah we talked a lot about courses and i
just think not like we are interested of
course because we can make courses that
might be successful and so and he
already does that i don't know how many
other people really care as much about
how much we nerded out about it but i
don't really care because i wanted to
know it and so it was usually good
uh let me tell you really quick about
this book i'm reading it's called empire
of the summer moon have you heard of
this
no but it sounds very uh it sounds like
a teenage girl book no it's about the
comanches the comanche indians do you
know what the comanches are
no what is that all right so let me this
is just a quick break how much time do
you spend reading i feel like every time
you get on the pod you're reading a
different book
are you reading like four hours a day
what's happening
i
when i say reading it's audio books and
i could do at least one a week
so wow like yeah like if i exercise if i
go for a walk i'll listen to it so and i
listen to it at like 1.2 speed so like a
10 hour book ends up becoming like eight
hours and so i could do that in a week
easy
is this a problem for you when i listen
to an audiobook and it's read by like a
professional narrator i just
hate it and i can't get into it but when
it's the author reading it i'm like okay
i'm kind of down with that is that a
problem just for me because it seems
like most are professional narrator
professional voice over actors or
whatever they call them it's actually is
a huge problem for me so i do two things
the first if i find a narrator that i
like i go oh oh
you find their other books that they've
read
yeah so if i find it sorry my phone was
going off if i find it like
who's your favorite narrator like some
random guy who nobody's ever heard
you're like yeah
craig smith
ron chernow ron chernow is a great
author he's he wrote titan he wrote
house of morgan i'll go and read books
uh he gets he has a great narrator that
i like the second thing so if i find a
narrator that i like i'll go and i'll
read uh something that they've done the
second thing that i do is i think more
celebrities should narrate books so i
just read this amazing book i loved it
it was by john steinbeck it was like
part fiction part not fiction and it was
read by lieutenant dan from forrest gump
okay you know come up his name's gary
rizik or resign or something and it made
the book so much better so lately i've
been trying to find books
sign i don't even know how to say his
name sinus is his name i want to go and
find books only by like certain
celebrities that i know and that makes
the book more fun so i actually no way
and and you know what's funny i always
think about this sometimes it's like the
reason i don't like i don't really read
like self-helpy business books that much
anymore and the reason i don't is i
found this one author that narrator
narrated literally like 200 like
self-healthy books and i looked at what
he was doing now and he like still
wasn't doing much i'm like well if this
[__] read all this stuff that it
should have worked like you would
like oh you i thought you were gonna say
they all sound the same but you're
saying
this guy read all these books and he's
still you know an average joe so [__] it
doesn't work yeah like i looked up like
how much he charged to read a book i'm
like dude what the heck like you're
making like 50 grand a year and you just
read yourself yeah what what the hell is
going on so i'm reading this book right
now called empire the sun of the summer
empire of the summer moon it's about the
comanche indians the comanche indians
was like 20 000 indians in america but
they were like in the colorado and west
area but when you think of indians like
you stereotype as like um like when i am
in my head i have this picture of like
the pilgrims and the indians coming
together and then eventually the white
people like mess them up so the com
the comanches were badass so they were
just like normal they were kind of
normal they weren't like that
particularly special but then they got a
hold of horses in the 1500s and they
mastered horses so much so that a
comanche on a horse what they could do
is they could get they could be riding
the horse lean to the side so you can't
see them and then pop up and shoot 20
arrows faster than one person could fire
one bullet and then reload it and fire
another and they were wild they were
wild wild wild they didn't even have the
word surrender in their language like it
wasn't a word
and uh this is great i'm now that's my
criteria now when i what do you look for
in founders when you invest
could you have been a comanche indian
right are you a comanche or not i want
to comanche you as a founder that i'm
investing they're crazy these guys were
like were bad to the bone and a lot of
stuff they didn't do was like great like
like in their
in their culture it was okay to torture
and kill captives and they would kidnap
people and so they're wild but the whole
story is about the history of them and
then also it centers around they kidnap
a family or they like take a family like
a white family and they kill most of the
family but they keep this 12 year old
girl and they end up like raising her
and she marries the chief and she gives
birth to someone who eventually becomes
the chief and the white people america
after like 25 years get her get her and
they think that they're saving her and
they bring her back and she's like no i
want to go back and they're like no look
lady you don't know what you're talking
about you need to be here and she's like
no no no like that they're my family now
and so out of protest because she like
inherited these like
these like um
you know these values of toughness she
was like fine and she'll see starved
herself and died
it's it's the craziest book i've been
reading you'll you'll have to read it's
called the
empire of the summer moon it's about the
community i can tell you right now
i'm not gonna read the book
definitely not gonna read the book but i
loved that story and i feel like i
already got the win i feel like if i go
in and read it now i'm gonna do a whole
bunch of work and not really get that
much more out of it than i already have
i'm so happy with what you just gave me
well i got like on this kick where i was
reading about navy seals and i was like
all right who else is badass and then i
got to the comanches so is it because
you met what's her name's husband and
he's an ex-navy seal 100
yes
i met him the other day he's awesome
okay great that's good um all right we
have a lot to go through
uh this is gonna be interesting i could
what do you want to start you want to
start with harold
uh no let's save him for a little bit
later uh let's do some cool ideas i have
a couple you have a couple i think
um you want to go first you want me to
go i want you to
okay which uh let's start with this okay
i think this one is as one of the more
interesting ideas it's kind of random so
i'll start with that it's pretty [__]
random but um
it's this thing called tonic fake data
and so i'm trying to chase this guy down
because i really want to invest in this
company now after i heard about it so my
so i have a cousin i got a couple
cousins that are in tech i got three i
think three or four cousins that are in
tech
one of them my cousin samir he tweeted
this and i think his tweet literally has
two likes which is just a shame because
like there's actually like an amazing
twitter thread i'll i'll retweet it
right now so people can go see it it's
on my twitter feed now um but he's like
you've heard about big data
but what about fake data you ever heard
of fake data i had never heard of this
so he's like check out this company
called tonic fake data
and uh they grew about 600 this last
year
and uh and he starts to like tie some
things together so he's like you
remember when hbo had that thing where
the intern accidentally sent an email to
every subscriber
and um
it's because you know they were doing a
test of a
like
some software system the email system or
whatever it is
but when a developer's doing a test they
have to input some dummy data right some
information um and and so typically like
you know a developer will just kind of
like make it up it'll be like
first comma last name you know like
they're just trying to get through the
task quickly so they're just like
inputting fake data you know just from
their head
and um
and so you know if you think about this
at kind of like a bigger level let's say
you're testing
um
you know you're uber and you're tr you
have a new feature in your app and so he
gives us example basically like let's
say your uber and you are releasing this
new thing about notifications um and so
you there's like this process of quality
control testing right so they'll they'll
have they'll try to like okay sign up as
a new user and try it okay let's say
you're already using log out log back in
pretend you got a new phone right
there's all these like if you have a
product that has hundreds of millions of
users that are living normal weird lives
there's all these random different paths
a user can take and you kind of need to
test your product through each
and so um
and so there was a guy this is kind of
the famous thing is
there was a guy who he had logged out of
his account on his wife's phone
but even when he logged out she kept
getting the notifications because of
just this like the developer didn't test
the feature properly of this use case
you go to a new phone you log in you
accept notifications then you log out
you're still getting notifications
somehow
and so
which we did all the time i would walk
around be like hey who here at the
office has an android let me see it real
quick right yeah yeah yeah exactly who's
got an android okay i think we tested
all of android it's like dude there's
like 200 models of this thing it's like
2 000 models you think you just tested
android because you know the one guy
who's an android bro like you know used
it for a second
so
what happened with this uber guy is uh
his wife got a notification that he was
going somewhere or like you know your
ride is ready or whatever and she's like
wait he's supposed to be at
some other place and she found out he
was cheating he ends up suing uber 47
million dollars because you know why
found out about this left-hand blah blah
the cheater sued uber which is hilarious
and so uh he's giving all these little
examples
i don't know if you're one or not it's
not in the thread i've done more than
so so he gives another example let's say
um
here's the last example
it's 2008 um
the financial system was crashing banks
are failing and banks owned at that time
if you remember like the subprime
mortgage crisis they had basically on
their books a whole bunch of mortgages
that they needed to get rid of
and so they needed to sell them super
fast because they were like they were at
risk of going bankrupt and so they they
set up a call center that any real
estate investor or buyer could call in
and make an offer on one of the
mortgages they had because like an
auctions like you know closing you know
final sale everything must go was that
was the idea
and so they hire palantir the big data
company that peter thiel started and
they say hey come up with a
recommendation engine that will figure
out what offer we should accept because
we don't have time to like vet each
offer as they come in it needs to be
quick like a garage sale type of
decisions of like hey i'll give you two
dollars for it will you take it yeah go
go ahead take it uh everything must go
and so um so the developers were like
okay we need to like test our
recommendation engine for like should we
or should we not accept the offer
but they couldn't use the data because
the data had like all this personal
sensitive information right it's a
person's name credit score their income
their address like it was too much
information the bank couldn't just give
it to palantir and say hey
use this real data to figure out what
offers we should and shouldn't accept
and so what they did was the developers
went to the bank's office they go inside
the building
and they looked at the data and they
said okay we understand we can't take
this data and use it for our models
but we can replicate this so like the
way a mannequin is a replica replica of
a human body or whatever they did that
to the real bank data system of all
these mortgages and so they created a
replica that would have the same like
let's say distribution and outliers and
whatnot but it was all dummy data it was
all fake data
and so they'd use this they go back they
create this thing uh they create the
model it's all successful it all works
so what happened is
i think the guy from palantir
took the spot i think he's for ex
palantir he spun out he is and was like
i'm going to create this yeah ian co i'm
going to create this for any business
because busi businesses need to be able
to generate fake data sets to test all
their scenarios from like the uber
example show me all the things that
users do all the all the different like
they do this step and this step and the
step and this step cool i need to be
able to simulate those steps um
accurately and so what they do is they
basically say all right people are
pretty sensitive about privacy and data
nowadays you got gdpr so companies can't
be using digi using their data for these
things or giving giving data to other
groups for it so tonic fake data can
basically analyze your data create
dummy data and then let your developers
or other developers use that data those
fake data that fake data that mirrors
the real data and so i thought this is
like such a niche problem that you would
only understand if you'd ever been
through this but then once you've been
through it you're like [__] this solves
a big problem that they have no other
way to solve and i love this this is the
opposite of a guy who can code makes a
to-do list app or makes a music
streaming you know like a playlist
generator based on the music you like
right those are the ideas everyone has
that everyone can do this is an idea no
one has that pretty much no one could do
and so i'm like dude i'm like super
bullish on this idea and i love this
i love this and especially now with
machine learning with machine learning
you need a lot of input data to make
recommendation engines better well how
do you do that how do you get more data
well you can simulate or create fake
data that mirrors a small sample of real
data so i just think it's awesome it
goes on two big mega trends privacy and
machine learning and i just loved that i
had never even thought about this this
is amazing how are they doing
i think they're doing well they raised
some money he said their group 600 in
2020 he what he does my cousin does is
he basically
helps people do what he did like
uh you're interested in tech but you're
not a programmer or a designer i'll help
you get your first sales job
inside your cousin
yeah so he went he went and worked at
sift science this like fraud detection
like machine learning thing similar
story by the way
ex facebook guys who are dealing with
the spam problem at facebook spun out
and created science so if you have any
platform they'll help you fight fraud
and spam
and uh using the same stuff that
facebook was building internally they
exported that idea that's my old import
expert framework and so he was the he
was like a you know just like a what
they call sdr like a sales development
rep basically just spam cold emails all
day
and uh and then you kind of work your
way up become a manager what's he do now
he teaches people how to get a gig so
he's basically like yo you want to break
into tech and get a sales job like cool
most people don't know how to how to
interview for this or how to like do
well with this so he takes you for one
month he tells you here's a bunch of
good companies like that you haven't
heard of tonic fake data they need sales
reps they have a great product it's a
technical dude really i'll help you i
hope you understand it and i'll help you
get do the job interview well and i only
make money once i place you and so he's
like a one-man recruiting firm right now
for this i think it's kind of a awesome
idea
i don't know i think he's just getting
started so i think he's got like you
know five people at a time right now per
month that he's helping get jobs like
very boutique at the moment i'll give
him a shout out so his twitter handle is
samir underscore joehr unfortunately no
one's gonna know how to spell any of
those things but if you go to my twitter
feed you'll see i retweeted his tweet
just now and i said that's great i
i i samir is more interesting almost
than than tonic i i i always thought
you're gonna say than me
well he might be you're pretty
interesting but this guy sounds great
too
i've always thought that you should that
that job that your cousin's doing samir
is doing that that could exist for all
types of positions because i've had when
when i was just breaking into silicon
valley and living there and i i would
have so many people email me and they
would say which company should i apply
to
and
for this role or that role i've always i
always thought that that could be a cool
service that's so cool that he's doing
that and he's got to take a cut like a
like a percentage of their first year's
earnings yeah it's like
if i help you get this job then i get x
x thousand dollars i don't know i don't
know what his pricing is exactly but i
get x thousand dollars but hey you just
got a job that's you know 85k base plus
bonuses whatever like are you cool
paying 4k to this guy to who got you
that job
like really was pretty hands-on with it
i think people will make that trade
every day of the week plus the companies
will pay a placement fee like once he
establishes himself a little more like
they already are playing recruiter fees
of 20 000 per person so
they will happily pay him once he builds
his name a little bit but it's not super
scalable i don't think he cares he's
just like dude i just want to make money
and i don't care like making 20k a month
would be effing sweet and if i could
just do that with my bare hands and not
have to like run a whole business and
have a big team great i'm going to do
that and i kind of think that's actually
pretty smart i've got a buddy who um was
a executive recruiter for years
and we
he eventually needed to
he was like i want to start my own thing
and i was like i'll hire you i'll be
your first client i was his first client
in his first 18 months he's done close
to a million dollars of sales
wow just from recruiting a one-person
recruiting of course he has like 10
years of experience and he's been doing
it for so it's not like it's just like
he just popped into it but recruiting is
an amazing business it's a really good
business for uh uh like if you have a
one to three person shop i think you
could kill it
it's pretty ridiculous
uh yeah of the of the like agency
service-y type businesses
headhunting executive recruiting
executive placements seems to be like
one of the best if you're gonna go into
service that's like one of the best
service industries to do
yeah i completely agree what's uh amazon
liquidation because you've been talking
to jack about it i saw the messages
you're hollering at them
well i just start to pay attention right
this is one of the one of the the meta
lessons of listening to this podcast
right you listen to this podcast you
should start seeing business as everyone
right like your cousin comes up to you
you're saying hello but you're looking
at everything that they're wearing and
you're thinking oh what's this [__]
what's that brand i've never heard of
that where'd that come from what is this
thing you're wearing on the wrist uh and
so you start to like see businesses
everywhere you go you go to the i told
you the story i was at the dentist he's
doing a cavity thing i'm looking at his
monitor wondering what software is that
oh who's selling software to dennis is
that that looks at the x-rays that it's
like this looks like it's from 1980 like
that's probably that's probably like a
super successful business because they
didn't have to update their software
that's how i know it's that good on
business whenever i drive by a library a
university or a church or a uh school
and i see someone it's named after
someone i'm always looking them up on
wikipedia i'm like right right where did
this come from because if you if you
have a library named after you you're a
baller and we have uh the ability of the
week i'm going to talk about this week
is exactly that so all right so anyways
the idea is you see business everywhere
so same thing happens with ads now every
time you see an ad it's not this
annoying thing to scroll by it's like
huh who are you that you can spend money
to get in front of me are you making
money who what is this business so i saw
this ad on tick tock
that was basically like
it was somebody receiving at their
doorstep not a package but a pallet of
packages like a normal person was like
so excited to open their door and they
like you know like you see it like a
shipyard like a palette of boxes just
taped up and they were all like a
mismatch of boxes it wasn't even like it
didn't look good so i was like what's
that and he said
get a palette of
amazon there's like amazon liquidation
get a pallet of amazon goods for like
ten dollars
that's ridiculous ridiculous like claim
and uh the one the one that i was
looking at well do you remember what the
service was called
okay so so look up this this url
charming so
c-h-a-r-m-i-n-g
charming z-r dot shop right so you
already know
this is some [__] drop shipper
[__] who is doing this
this is not a long-term brand
they are investing into charming
charming
er got shot shop
okay
uh okay okay so yeah so it's like a drop
yes it's just [__] they're just trapped
right okay
like the crappy leggings that you see on
tick tock so look in the thread that me
and look at the thread that me and jack
and you are in and look click that
exactly so this says huge value backlog
picking liquidation package 9.99
and then you see these giant like from
an amazon warehouse packages and it's
basically returns uh and you can get
like the medium value you get the large
you get the super large this is a super
large one which i think is or the whole
thing which is what the picture is of is
60 60
so 60 for the whole thing and so here's
what it says
uh if you just scroll down their site
and you know it's good because look at
this it has like the flashing yellow and
red text so like this is some again drop
shipper [__] who's like i'm
gonna optimize this limited stock it's
flashing red
he goes in the united states and europe
amazon ebay and other e-commerce
platforms have too many returns and
there's no redundant warehouses to
accommodate those returns
therefore as a top liquidation company
we've collected these returns at a very
low price
and put them repackaged into pallets for
sale
some of the packages in the pallets lack
the outer packaging like there's no box
um some of them and the functions are
normal and do not affect the use at all
this is why we can sell these at low
prices
and it says this is a mixed palette of
amazon bulk which is also like junk
um
there's just a whole bunch of random
things and it's like you get what you
get and you don't get upset
you know that's the only thing
listen to their sizing it's medium large
and super large
with three fire emojis by the way
and the picture is like
a palette wrapped in plastic it looks
like a like a nintendo
and like an oven a coffee maker
do
we have to by the way right okay 5 to 14
businesses yeah we need to do that by
the way you want to grow the youtube
channel here's a stunt that becomes a
youtube video that's i ordered an amazon
liquidation thing for 60 bucks here's
the unboxing of my liquidation so i
don't know where you're at if not if you
don't want to do it i'll do it but uh
but we should do this and film it and i
think i think you'd be great at this
your american pickers days are going to
come back in handy here all right so let
me just tell you a few other hilarious
things
oh customer service guess what his
customer service email is sam what is it
is it
is it help at a help desk at charming's
easy shop no is it sub service is it
returned no is it like big baller 69
yeah speed arver speed of villa 96
gmail.com
oh my god this is awesome
did you saw a facebook ad for this tick
tock i've been getting tic tac ads for
this thing like crazy i bet you this
guy's found some arbitrage where this is
hitting on tick tock and he's just he's
advertising or retargeting me at least
because i'm seeing quite a bit of it but
there is this market and so i i
mentioned this to jack because jack who
is our clever friend jack smith who
just finds [__] like this before we do
typically he's he's always like into
interesting stuff so he had told me
about this like a year ago he's like yo
there's this amazon liquidation thing
you should check this out
and i was like what what is that and
then he sent me something that was
actually like the high class version of
this so uh so a blue lot
yeah so bluelots.com so that's the yc
version of this i don't think it took
off what they were doing was they were
taking these pallets these liquidations
and they were just listing them for like
an instant auction like a live auction
it's like the retail price of these
items would be 500 you can buy it for
14. go like just like buy now and
they're just basically taking junk i
think on kind of consignment
and um
and flipping it and so this is like a
flipper business of liquidations that i
don't really know anything else about i
just thought this was funny and
interesting and i don't know what do you
think about this so let me tell you what
i would do i wouldn't do it the way the
blue lot's doing it so there's this
company that we wrote about in 2020 it's
called it's it's called unclaimed
baggage that's all it's called and right
what it does it's based out of i believe
alabama scottsboro alabama it has like
200 employees it was launched in 1970 by
a guy named hugo owens
and
when he launched it basically the idea
was he made a deal with the local
airport and it says any luggage that has
been there for like 30 days or whatever
it is you know we'll take it off your
hands and they just have a huge store
and you and they also have an online
store but they have a location it's like
a warehouse that you can go and
buy all the stuff and all the stuff
that's in it and i believe he's crushed
it and so it kind of looks like um
kind of you know like remember like ross
stores or like uh marshall
yeah yeah the stores where it's like
it's not high quality [__] it's mostly
crap but you can find some gems but it's
like just there's stuff all over the
place
um
you know and it's like fun it's kind of
fun like you go there and like i don't
even know what this thing is but like
this bluetooth speaker i don't need it
but i'm going to buy it i'm going to buy
it right um that's what i would do with
this is i would have a massive store
and just sell this stuff i wouldn't do
it online um i would do it 100 in person
in a cheap area where it's relatively
low income and i would have tons of
stuff and by the way by the way the
unclaimed baggage thing it says
uh cool bags get lost uh and then 99.5
percent of them like get back to their
owners but then it says less than 0.03
are never claimed and so they made an
agreement with all the airlines it says
with uh says we will kind of give these
bags a second life we'll take it off
your hand so you don't have these bags
unclaimed bags are just sitting here and
we can resell
um we can resell the items that are from
it they say only about a third one third
of the unclaimed items can be resold
they go through like a kind of a qa
process that says
and they have about 7 000 uniquely
discounted items for sale each day where
where they got from from unclaimed
baggage and then they have like an
online store
and they they clean so what they do is
they clean the clothes before they get
them they clean
70 000 clothing items a month and a
million people go to the store every
single year and it's about 150 miles
outside of atlanta so people are going
like just for this store it's like it's
like it's like a sticky type of like
cute thing to do
i have a friend you should check this
guy out on twitter he's pretty
interesting this guy's sunny bird bird
with a y
um
he has a ret he created like a returns
business he had a clothing brand and he
saw one of the challenges is
somebody sent something back for a
return or an exchange and he was selling
like suits that were like in a few
hundred dollar suits or something and
then what he did was he was like all
right look
um
you
you uh
he basically was like all right you send
back the suit now i need to like get
this stain off or i need to reapply the
tag or i need to do this other thing
otherwise this is like an unsellable
item and so he like got a facility
basically in north carolina somewhere
and started accepting these items
for him for his own returns first and
started getting good at refurbishing
them like reapply the label get the
stain out re-steam it so it's not
wrinkly or crumbled up or like he's like
dude
i can't even explain the number of
variations of how people send back the
[__] wrong and he's like so we just had
to handle all those variations and once
he started doing it for himself he was
like oh cool i could just make this any
brand you could just if you have items
like this just send them to us
we'll turn them over seven dollars per
item or something like that and then
we'll like you can go resell that item
we brought it back to life for you to be
able to resell as new
and um and i thought that was pretty
interesting he's doing well and he's
like it was just one of those like kind
of messy businesses that's like
you wouldn't i wouldn't really want to
start it but i totally think it's going
to kick ass for whoever is willing to do
the work there
in
2014 when i launched my first conference
hustle con i
was like crazy cheap and i didn't have a
lot of money and
costco is famous for like taking so many
returns
and i bought like
maybe it was a second conference but i
think i bought like ten thousand dollars
worth of stuff from costco ranging from
tables to tablecloths to like two grand
worth of soda and we didn't end up using
a lot of it and i was like let's just
return it and i returned like three to
four thousand dollars worth of stuff and
i was like yeah i'm so i'm so cool i'm
like getting money back so big deal i'm
saving
and one uh it i like to this day i still
lose sleep over this because
i found out there the cashiers were like
giving me a hard time they're like uh
looking at me funny and uh
and the reason why and i kind of
overheard them say it they threw all of
it away
oh really they just threw it right away
it was like but i was like but this is
like a case of soda that's like still in
the wrapper like there's nothing wrong
and they're like our rulers would just
throw it all away and i was
devastated that was one of the biggest
regrets that i've ever had is returning
four thousand dollars worth of stuff
that was like consumables that they
ended up just throwing away like it it
breaks my heart that i did that and uh
so at least you have an answer to the
question of like what's your biggest
regret in life you got your answer
actually this should be a thing people
do there's all these questions of like
oh you know what's the best what's your
favorite movie what's the biggest regret
you ever had you know what's what's been
a turning point in your life whatever
this is random questions that you only
get so often but it's very [__] hard
to think of a good answer on the spot
and so we should all just do ourselves a
favor and like one day just be like all
right i'm gonna i'm gonna write down my
answers to all these questions and then
you have them and i've got two because
if you have a great answer in that
moment you're like a star because nobody
else can one of them
that's one of them the second one was
when i was in college i went to a tip a
guy like i was staying at a hotel and
the shuttle was driving me around and i
gave the guy like 20 and he goes oh well
thank you and i said oh no you need it
and i meant to say like you earned it or
something like that and i say oh no you
need it and
i was devastated i was like oh my god
i'm angry that i [__] it
i'm haunted by that i said you need it
and i was like oh my god that was the
worst thing i could have said
just to say you deserve it or you earned
it is stupid already i don't know why i
was right right already bad yeah
oh it's like that those things i think
about all the time i'm like what was i
thinking
right yeah that'll hit you once a week
and you just have a wave of sadness like
that's like the bad version of you know
the flight attendant or you check in at
the front desk or whatever for your at
the airport and they'll like hand you
the boarding pass like have a good
flight you're like you too yeah you walk
away
yeah and you're like
bleep that out if people are listening
to the car with their kids all right you
can leave that one out so
okay so i'll tell you by the way i have
a theory on this stuff which is
it's my halloween costume rule all right
so so what is this there's an art to
these stories so the way you just did it
was perfect which was
you tell the story it does the job like
you you did something regrettable
but it's not like you said like you know
uh you know i hit my girlfriend back
they said whoa bro like you know you're
not actually supposed to like put some
dark [__] out there or something really
bad that makes you look bad like these
are things that are kind of endearing
like it's endear like it's it's funny
that you did it you made an honest
mistake and then you recognize it and it
still haunts you to this day oh what a
good guy and we all had a laugh and i
feel like i got to know you and you're
an interesting guy it's
so this happens with halloween costumes
one time i went on a i was in australia
it was halloween and they had a booze
cruise and so we went on and i always
remember there was this there was you
know the halloween thing most guys dress
up as whatever but most most females
there's like the it's like okay to be
kind of [__] on halloween right they
were okay to dress a certain way to like
kind of like you could spice it up
but
you don't want to have your halloween
costume be accurate and inconvenient so
i saw this one girl she came on the on
the booze cruise and she was dressed up
as a bushel of grapes and so she just
had balloons all over her body like
green balloons and so she looked like
like you know like like drapes on a like
she was this the vine or whatever and
there's grapes all over
but she couldn't like she couldn't have
fun on the cruise like she was bumping
into everybody everybody hated her she
couldn't dance she could barely breathe
it was like so hot in there and like she
paid the price for having this creative
and accurate looking costume and in my
head when i saw this bushel of grapes
girl just struggling the whole cruise
she couldn't even get off this boat she
was just stuck there in her costume i
was like oh the halloween principle
which is like
there you don't want to be you don't
want to answer all questions accurately
if it's going to make you look bad
so there's a way to answer something
there's a way to do the game to play the
game but still look good in the process
i can't believe you're making frameworks
up when you're like 18.
yeah as i'm drunk on this boost cruise
this is what i was thinking about i like
made a mental note never make this
mistake as i saw her because i would do
this i would come up with a clever idea
and then it'd be like i'd have like the
most inconvenient night so i i it
resonated with me what rami actually
said something amazing that i that it
was just one line and he said when i
think of copywriting it's uh he goes uh
effective not cute
you remember when he said something yeah
he's like effective not cute not clever
something like that yeah and and that
would and i i think that's always the
best i'm like whenever i see websites
that are i'm like that's not effective
it's cute not effective be effective
don't be charming or whatever he said
yeah exactly you want to do one more or
you want to talk about i'm eager to talk
about harold but we could do one more if
you want well let's do harold because
it's actually it actually relates to the
liquidation amazon liquidation thing
i'll tell you why so okay so where did
this come from this is the
cue the music billy of the week is this
guy harold alfond i had never heard of
this guy did you know did you know this
name before i wrote this here no and i
added a bunch of stuff though for you
okay great so let me give you kind of
like the brief story and then you fill
in the gaps of what you found
interesting so here's the brief story i
or i'll go backwards tarantino style
last time we were on here or two
podcasting or something like that we
talked about universal basic income
which is this idea of like
every year you would just get like a ten
thousand dollar check like oh why like
oh so you know everybody it's like
social well social service or whatever
social security for everybody
um
including non-retired people unemployed
everybody
so i had said oh i heard this
interesting idea and i forgot that it
was chamath who had said this that i
heard it from uh of a birth dividend
instead which is basically giving
somebody some money at birth if you if
you're a citizen the government gives
you x dollars at birth and the beauty of
it is it's going to compound over 18
years so by the time you're 18
they only had to give you a thousand it
was invested in the economy and then it
grows over time to this larger amount by
the time you're 18 you want to go for
college you have something there so two
things happened a bunch of people on
twitter were tagging me saying dude i
actually did this for my kid
and look at this and so some guy was
sharing screenshots of like i put in i
think it was put in a thousand dollars
or something like that and he's like and
then i added
um
i think it was 50 or 100 a month and he
showed that the balance was now 93 000
that was in this and he's like how much
how much had they invested crazy that it
grew
i don't know i don't know all the
details but he was basically saying like
yeah i did this for my kid and
you know it was a great idea for me
and um i thought okay that's interesting
and so then i saw that somebody somebody
goes
yeah it's like harold alfond and main
i say okay i don't even know what any of
those words mean what are you talking
about so i google it and basically
there's this guy harold alfond he was
kind of like a shoe mogul basically he
he uh he started off as a shoe boy
working in a shoe store i don't know
what the job title is but he went from
like shoe boy to manager then he left
and him and his dad buy a factory they
buy a factory shoe factory and they flip
it in three years to a larger company
and then he goes and he buys another
factory called the dexter either like
the place is called dexter or something
like that but it's like the dexter shoe
factory something like that
and he becomes he becomes a a private
labeler so he's making the shoes that
are being sold in jcpenney in sears and
a bunch of other like uh department
stores nation nationwide and so that
that grew pretty fast as he became their
their shoe provider
and uh and then he says all right it's
i'm so worried like if jcpenney cuts me
off or they're always putting price
pressure on me because they know i'm
they're they're my big customer like
screw it i'm going direct so this guy
hires a sales force creates a public
facing brand called dexter shoes or
whatever
and takes it like kind of nationwide
himself starts to be successful but the
thing that's interesting is or there's
two things so his business story gets
interesting because he actually ended up
inventing the outlet store which is
similar to what we were talking about
with the liquidation thing so in any
factory he knew this because he owned
factories in any factory not 100 of the
shoes are
like up to snuff up to the standard
right so what do you do with the like
non
first grade shoes that were made uh he's
like you either throw them away like you
mentioned
or you would sell it to you called like
a jobber i don't know what that means
but you'd sell it to a jobber for a
dollar he would go mark it up and sell
it for five dollars somewhere he's like
hey that's pretty good like 5x uh why
don't i just do that myself a job is
typically it's just a company that
distributes so it's a they have shelf
space at kmart and they just need to
fill it
gotcha gotcha okay exactly so so what he
did was he's like i'll create my own and
so he creates this this kind of
signature look this log cabin looking
store
and he's like this is where you can go
get the stuff for cheap because these
are the the kind of like refurbished or
not quite
like kind of odd size slightly imperfect
and so he creates an outlet store he's
so he creates the concept of outlet
stores it gets really popular other
brands start to see that oh wow this
guy's like he's turning his waste into
revenue uh his cost into into profits
like okay we want to do the same so they
start opening up stores right next to
his off the highway and so that's how
you started to get these like fact uh
what do we call like outlet malls where
you would get a bunch of different
stores all putting their outlet stuff
together here and so that was kind of
like one of his inventions anyways he
ends up selling the company to berkshire
hathaway so he sells it to warren
buffett
uh for 433 million dollars in an all
stock deal of berkshire
and i think you added some notes here
but all i know is that later on
um
warren buffett apparently said like you
know this was one of the worst
investments i ever made so why did he
say that what i added there was
basically when he bought it i think he
bought it in the 80s when he bought it
he said it's this business is amazing he
and he wrote dexter i can assure you
needs no fixing it's one of the best
managed companies charlie charlie and i
have ever seen in our business lifetimes
he's as a business jewel he goes when i
go to work i sing there's no business
like the shoe business he thinks he's
excellent
um but what the issue that happened
around that time is basically
uh cheap international stuff started
coming into coming into america and he
said something like he goes well cheap
imported shoes from low-wage countries
started coming um but someone forgot to
tell the dexter's managers and their
workers about that and they just forgot
to address it and so over time he he
predicted that i was going to make about
120 150 million a year in profit after a
handful of years he ends up losing tons
of money he merges it with burlington
coat factory or at least tries to and
eventually it goes
it it goes it's done and the a big
problem was that harold started the
company in a small town in maine where
basically 2 000 people worked and at
this point they were mostly older people
and buffett was like well we just lost
all this money it was a horrible he goes
if you look at the guinness book of
world records it goes down it's the
worst deal ever but the worst part is
now all these people are all out of work
and they pretty much are too old to
learn a new trade and we and they're
screwed and so he calls it one of the
worst deals of all time the quote was we
lost our entire investment which we
could afford but many workers lost a
livelihood that they could not replace
uh okay good good good guy warren
buffett all right so so okay this is
where okay harold hof harold uh alphon
now has
a bunch of money a bunch of berkshire
stock berkshire stock continues to
appreciate over time so he he sold it in
1993 berkshire has just continued to
grow and grow and grow uh over the years
so anyways i think he owned one over one
percent of berkshire hathaway stock wow
that's kind of incredible because i
don't i don't know what berkshire's
market cap is now dan check check virgin
market cap now but he sold it an all
stock deal so whatever that 433 million
was worth if he held uh it ended up
being worth a hell of a lot more so
what's interesting is
like you said the guy's in maine and
what he decided to create he starts
giving away so he starts giving right
he's like okay i'm gonna uh live you
need a new library i'll fund it the the
university of maine you need a football
field i'll i'll uh i'll fund it
berkshire hathaway 640
billion uh and by the way dan check what
it was in 1993 when he sold i want to
see how much it's grown
so
so he starts giving away one thing he
decides to do is he says you know
education is the most important thing i
didn't get to go to college just because
of my what my opportunities were i want
to make sure everybody has that
opportunity i think it's one of the
greatest opportunities you could have
so he creates uh a pledge where he says
i will give 500
to every baby born in maine
on their kind of like birthday you know
when they're born that in a 529 account
right so this like special kind of like
tax advantage saving account if you open
up your account i'll put 500 in
and
by the time they're 18 that will have
grown uh over time they'll have
appreciated um and so he starts doing
this and at the beginning he does it for
like you know whatever 300 people then a
few thousand people
so now life is let me just break down
some of the numbers here so
60 million dollars has been given away
to babies in maine for their college
tuition uh that's 117 000 babies that
have taken him up on his offer for free
money uh statewide so it's a it's the
largest statewide college savings
program is sponsored by this one dude
and his like family trust i suppose
families the families because they open
up the account they can kind of like his
he was big on matching so everywhere he
gave he wanted the recipient to match in
some way whether it's money or effort or
you have to do something rather than
just give so in this you had to open the
account which was a bunch of people
weren't doing that before this and the
second thing was you can then match the
500 that goes in because you realize
it's a good idea and so
here's the basic math if you had just if
you just took the 500 by the time you're
18 it's about 2 000 right so it's gone
up about 4x in the 18 years
but if you contribute 50 a month it's 25
000 by the time you're 18. and that 25
dollars or so the 50 a month that's like
achievable for many many families and
then if twenty five thousand dollars it
like can pay for for you know state
college tuition and whatnot give you an
education and so i kind of love this i
thought this was a baller move to like
build up your hometown and he's given
away 500 million dollars just in maine
across various programs i thought that
was pretty remarkable the foundation has
a billion in assets so they give away
about five oh sorry six to eight percent
a year of their total assets
and i think his son is like a senator in
maine right i think like that's right
grandson
uh so the family is i mean i guess
they're legends in maine that's pretty
baller this makes me want to like get
wealthy just for that reason
are you gonna go back to st louie and do
a little something or what
i don't know i've been out for so long
but did you you can make a big donation
to belmont
you're belmont's finest alumni
did you um
i'll put you in the spot did you donate
anything to the haiti thing or the
afghanistan or any other cause this year
uh we did the a bunch of stuff for the
wildfires which i don't know if that was
this year or not uh
and then the other one was uh charity
water we try to support i don't know if
we did it this year or not
um and then the last one uh sonia if she
sees anything that's like for like
animals or like it's like she's a vegan
so she if she sees the animals or like
distressed somewhere she really wants to
give and so we'll give a little bit
there but we're not big givers i was
actually we were talking about this the
other day it's like we have this idea
like my wife really wants to open up an
orphanage in india this has been her
dream since we were dating she's been
talking about this like she wants to
have like if you go to india you see
these like tiny tiny kids on the street
begging it's like heartbreaking so she
wants to open up an orphanage where you
know they can kind of have a place and
not be on the street
and uh
and i told her i was like you know like
i feel like we made it and she's like no
like when we really make it i was like
you know that time will never come we
should just start giving now
proportionally whatever we can give now
and then like when the time comes that
we can open up a full orphanage great it
will already have been like doing the
thing it's taking some suffering away
for some people and so we were literally
just talking about this so i don't
really give either i we gave um low
digit
thousands to the haiti and afghan stuff
and that was like a big that was the
biggest donation i've ever made right um
and
maybe sorry it was it might have been
two grand i think one thousand each and
i tip that that's new we don't ever do
that and i realize that's a huge mistake
that is such a huge mistake and i think
it's a huge mistake for for one major
reason two major reasons one it makes
you feel so good to do that even you
know no one has to know but i guess i'm
breaking that rule i'm telling a bunch
of people but um the second thing it can
like
giving away money i think will make you
earn more so john rockefeller was famous
he actually gave 10 of his income every
single year starting at age like 12.
like the year he started making money he
always gave it away we talked to uh we
we joke about mormons they do this a ton
a lot of christians they do tithing i
guess that's 10 i don't know how
different other i don't know how other
religions do i'm sure each religion has
like their version of this we should
totally give more and we don't and it's
kind of messed up but
it is i think it's wrong um i i like
kind of convinced myself i'm like well
if i i'll just tip a lot which is like
kind of [__] but it's not entirely
[__] but it's half [__] we
should totally give more we don't give
nearly enough um and so that's cool to
read the story whenever i read these
stories i'm like i want to get wealthier
just to do this there's a guy who um
what was the guy's name in san francisco
and there was this amazing article what
it was called the billionaire who gave
it all away you know what i'm talking
about his name was patrick um uh uh
patrick feeney i think is his name
patrick feeney um
let me look it up so anyway his name's
chuck feeney so he created the basically
the stores that you i'm going off of
memory i read this book a while ago he's
90 years old he currently lives in san
francisco i i'm reading this uh
the building
billy of the week on him chuck feeny i
remember you brought up feeny the
billionaire who wanted to to die broke
and is now
and did it basically
and he's now worth two million dollars
at his height was he the one somebody
wrote a book called die with zero or
something like that yeah that's a
different that's a different topic but
it's also good but basically the idea is
like a lot of people wait to give all
their money away this guy did it when he
was live his name was chuck feeny he
basically created
when you're
if you uh go to china and you're not
china
heated japan if you're on your way back
from japan you can go to the duty-free
shop uh he basically
he basically invented that and now he's
got a bunch of duty-free shops they're
they're quite famous i can't remember
what they are but his uh it was cash
flowing like crazy and so at its height
he had something like it was multiple
digit billions i believe eight billion
dollars and that's how much he's given
it away so he's given all of it away
except for two million dollars and he
currently has an apartment in san
francisco that costs him four or five
thousand dollars a month and that two
million is all he's got left crazy
fascinating i remember reading about him
and i was like i want to get rich just
to do that so pretty cool but like a lot
of people when they start making money
i'm like oh i don't know that
you know yeah i don't know what what is
the thought there is some thought that
like kind of like blocks you but
what i can't even put my finger on it's
not like i can say
well i'm thinking about it this way but
that's the wrong way it's like i don't i
think i'm just not thinking about it or
i'm
i'm thinking about it and then it kind
of becomes a heavy topic because i think
i should do more and then i feel guilty
and then i just move on with my life and
i just do nothing i distract myself you
know i don't want to blow up his spot
too much but the guest we just had on
ramit i've heard stories i've heard that
he is a very good giver
oh yeah i i like hearing how people give
i have a friend who
uh as soon as he made a bunch of money
gave a ton of laptops away and i thought
that you know there's like a
there's something really cool about when
you give somebody a knowledge engine or
or like a monetization engine
it's like
you know it's sort of like a teach
amanda fish thing but you're not
teaching anybody anything you're just
giving them a tool
that if used well
can generate like kind of an infinite
number of returns and so i like that
idea of like you know whether it's
microlending or it's or it's uh
you know that what was that project
where they dropped a tablet off do you
remember this they dropped a tablet off
in the middle of africa with no
instructions
and did you know what i'm talking about
so i might butcher some of the details
they ran this experiment they left an
android tablet
which i think had like nothing
like kind of like nothing on it i think
it was like a wiped
reset thing maybe it was just like the
boot sequence and they just left it in
this like village in africa and uh
and then they came back like a year
later
and
like the whole village had learned how
to use this comp how to use the tablet
they had like found it booted up got an
operating system on it had apps it was
like running it like they had like
learned all put all these education
games on it or whatever it was like yeah
dan just linked it here i didn't
remember the exact story so
i guess it's ethiopia so a box
a box of zoom tablets was dropped off in
ethiopian village to kids who had never
seen a computer before and by the time
they came back they had not only taught
themselves how to use it they were like
modifying the android operating system
on it to like work better for themselves
it was kind of this like really
inspiring
story it was almost so inspiring that
i'm like
all right is this a little bit of
[__] or what like i kind of don't
really care but
i like that i think that's that just
shows how much power there is in such a
simple act
yeah i think it's great we should have
we should organize something for like
our listeners to like yeah we should do
something via the pod let's give some
let's give something fun via the pod
well
the way that we gave to the afghanistan
i think we only gave him a thousand
dollars so it wasn't like that big of a
deal but the guy his name is saul uh
s-o-w-s-o-l space and then orwell is his
last name he owns uh examined.com he
just tweeted out that he was gonna do
this and he was like i'm gonna give away
he's like i vetted this i know where the
money's gonna go to for this i know
exactly what's happening you if you
trust me then you'll then you can trust
that this is gonna be good and he raised
four hundred thousand dollars off a
couple tweets
um and that was pretty amazing uh yeah
and it sounds badass so we'll have to do
something like that uh i think there's a
lot of work to vetting in haiti sarah's
you know haiti had this massive
earthquake you know about that yeah yeah
and my mother-in-law is from haiti and
she's got this brother so my
my my mother-in-law's brother
yeah no my brother yeah my uncle i guess
he is a haitian immigrant and one and
when the
another earthquake happened what he did
was he got all of his friends to donate
a little bit of money collectively added
up to like a hundred thousand dollars so
he had a hundred thousand dollars uh
maybe he had two hundred thousand
dollars something like that um a lot but
not enough that it's like too much and
he took a hundred grand in cash and one
dollar bills and five dollar bills and
then he hired a private plane and they
bought tons of toilet paper paper towels
and peanut butter they flew into haiti
they gave out the peanut butter and gave
out the toilet paper and then he had all
this cash and he's like dude they just
needed money to buy [__] and like do us
currency was good so i just started
giving everyone five dollar bills so
anyone i could find i would just give
him five dollar bills and then he goes
and then we stayed there for a day and
we gave it all away and then we just
came right back and i was like that's
pretty baller that's pretty great
uh and so i don't know something like
that it's inspiring to hear so we're
gonna have to do something about that if
somebody's listening to this and they
have a good idea of a way for us to give
that i would say is
what my hope is that it's kind of like
in line with the values of the pod like
if you listen to this you kind of know
what we're all about what we respect
like i respect that kind of like
tab giving tablets to people who never
had a computer before i think that's
kind of amazing and so if you can think
of a good way for us to do this where
you kind of you know where the money's
going you know it's legit you know that
this is going to like actually help
people um
definitely hit us up hit us up on
twitter or whatever give us ideas
can we go a little bit over can i have
can i there's one something you want i
have a lot of stuff on here did you see
i did a ton of research on a variety of
different stuff and you totally
overlapped with a lot of my stuff scroll
down look at all that stuff i'm not
gonna get you at all it's like so much
work that i put in we're gonna have to
get to it next week but
can we wrap up with the theory of of the
future of venture capital
yeah
because i'm curious what your opinion is
is why you're saying this is that one of
the things you research or you want me
to spiel i want you to tell me your
opinion
so i was thinking about this um
so basically i was like all right
venture capital i think is a great place
to be
because i think technology is driving a
ton of progress so you basically
if you want to bet on the future of
humanity and where a lot of growth is
going to come from investing in
technology is the way to do it that's
pretty clear to me all right
so
within that how do you perform well so i
was thinking about all right you have
venture capital venture capital is kind
of changing and people like to talk
about this so here's my theory why i
think
it's changing because uh like a there's
just new like the secrets out that you
should be investing in in technology so
you have like soft bank coming over the
top with the 100 million 100 billion
dollar vision fund and you have tiger
global do you know what's going on with
tiger well i just know that i see tiger
global everywhere i believe tiger global
it started a guy named chase coleman his
wife was in like some uh actually
documentary about being like filthy rich
years ago and he uh it was a hedge fund
at first it was just a hedge fund like a
boring like maybe high speed trading
hedge fund right
yeah i have high frequency trading you
got to read this subset i mean obviously
not now we're on the pod but it's called
playing different games it's by this guy
everett randall
phenomenal sub phenomenal blog post
about what tiger is doing and how
they're playing a different game
and um
basically what it talks about is like
uh what's the most beautiful headline by
the way if you want to learn about how
to package content into good stuff this
is a beautiful headline it says playing
different games
the tiger phenomenon beautiful headlines
it's not it's not too clickbaity either
it's like seven unbelievable things
about tire no it's like
it's it's a it's a this guy has a a
point of view or a thesis on what
they're what they're doing because to
everybody else it looks a little bit
crazy because what you were seeing was
oh new funding around happens tigers in
it tigers in it tigers say dude how much
how many deals are these guys doing they
can't possibly be vetting and seeing
this many deals this is unbelievable
pace and so what he talks about is that
they're playing a different game so a
normal fund says okay i raised this fund
i'm going to deploy it over the next
three years and that's what i told my my
investors i was going to do so over
three years i'm going to find the best
deals i can i'll be super selective i
want to find the best deals and then i'm
going to maximize the sort of like uh
the sort of return
the return i'm going to get the irr
and um
he says what tiger is going to do is
like i'm going to deploy as much capital
as humanly possible
at a 18 irr so i'm not trying to
maximize irr i'm trying to maximize the
gross dollars
that i could shove into a pipe that will
give me 18
so i don't want to fall below 18
but i don't want to try to get to 28 if
it means i'm gonna deploy half as much
money so it's a very different game so
so this happens in e-commerce all the
time you have two people in e-commerce
one one brand says we want to maximize
our roi or return on ad spend as some
people say well just call roi so they
want to put a dollar in and make three
dollars out and they're and if they if
they get two dollars out they feel bad
if they get four dollars out they feel
great and so they they spend as much as
they can while they're getting they
spend like as long as they can maintain
a certain like above 3x roi
and they have other people that say
no you know what like i'm happy as long
as my roi is like yeah somewhere but
somewhere above 1.5 if it's above 1.5
all i'm gonna do is just add more money
into the top of this thing i'm gonna
shove more money in because i'm taking a
larger number and i'm multiplying it by
a smaller multiple but my base the base
amount of money i'm shoving into the
pipe is getting bigger so this that's my
return so you have different strategies
so what are you saying was tiger's doing
this in vc they're basically trying to
deploy way more money way faster
so that their and their returns look
better because it's instead of deploying
it over three years and being selective
they're deploying it all in six months
and so now if it comp if it starts to
return
it's going to already have a faster rate
of return because the money got deployed
whereas the vc might have held the money
for three years being selective about it
and so solving the hard problem of
making sure that the companies are going
to collectively do eighteen percent irr
well they're sort of saying look uh if
if the best guys who are selective are
gonna hit 30 40
we can hit 18 just by
getting we we can hit 18 by doing a lot
of deals and sort of like a law of large
numbers we should still get there
because technology and aggregate the
index is going to do something close to
18 and plus as we develop this
reputation of being
we are a trusted fast deal maker you
want money come to tiger global we'll
get you money in 24 hours we'll get you
a lot of money you don't have to do this
whole dance with the other vcs and
they're going to debate bring you and
they overpay
and they're like yeah cool what's your
what valuation you want 50 make it 60.
and it's like oh okay cool i'll take
your money so they're getting into a lot
of deals and a lot of good deals because
they're not price sensitive they're fast
and they're aggressive and they're
building a track record because when you
do so many deals they're going to have a
bunch they can point to as like yeah
tiger was the one behind this winner and
they'll just sweep all their losers
under the table and you don't have to
worry about that so they'll build
reputation fast too so i thought this
was kind of interesting so i would say
there's a whole bunch of reasons why vc
changes this is actually not even what i
was talking about my thought was if
you're creating a fun today
you really the winning strategies are
um
you you play a different game which is
the tiger one so that's that's strategy
one
you play by a different set of rules
than everybody else i love that strategy
though another example of that is uh uh
when chamoth moved up market to spax so
chamoth was doing early stage tech
investing series a series b he's
competing with sequoia and benchmark and
everybody else
and then he's like oh dude spax uh spax
you know like spax weren't in vogue
until he started to make the pencil the
mechanism had been around but they
weren't popularized and not everybody
was trying to do a spack and then he
started this wave because he's like huh
there's a bunch of companies that want
to go public
i can take them public faster and get
them a higher valuation
and basically i can do late super late
stage stuff and basically make 10x my
money in one year um and so he and so he
does once back he's like oh this is
amazing he hits back a then he
trademarks back beast backseat spec d
all the way through spack z trademark 26
of these he's like dude this is a money
printer i'm 10xing my money i'm gonna
i'm going to do this 26 times if i can
but the verdict's still out on that on
that strategy i believe right the
sponsors the sponsors are making their
money dude they make their money
regardless it's the retail investor who
joins in and says i'm going to invest in
in this spec
they are getting a questionable return
but the sponsor chamath what he's doing
so here's the model by the way i learned
this recently so
i might be oversimplifying it i might
have some details wrong this is i was at
a dinner with somebody who's doing a
spec and i was like yo
can you say who
no i was like i was like tell me the
numbers behind this i was like i was
like are these guys getting filthy rich
i feel like they're making a lot of
money doing this because just of how
many they're trying to do this must be
i'm wondering it's like it's
unbelievable so here's what here's how
the economics of us back work
you let's say you're chama
you have great reputation so for those
who don't know what a spak is a spac is
a special purpose acquisition
corporation or something so it's
basically a blank check holding company
so you go to the public market and you
you list your spac
there and you say give me 400 million
dollars i'm going to take that 400
million dollars and i'm going to go find
a company to to invest in
and so so he goes to the public market
he says i don't know who i'm going to
invest in but i'm going to invest in
somebody but his reputation was strong
enough that he was able to raise 400 500
a billion dollars bill ackman i think
seven billion dollars or something crazy
for their specs but they don't even know
who they're gonna acquire you have a
deadline
you have a two year i think clock 18
months two years or something like that
you have a deadline and and if you don't
pay if you don't buy a company you have
to buy it back plus a certain amount of
interest yeah there's like a warrant
basically
so um so so and that's what's happening
now with specs a lot of spac investors
have been sitting around waiting for the
company to make do a move they're just
they're they're it's like a coupon like
you can basically say give me my money
back and they have to give you your
money back and maybe plus i'm interested
i'm not sure exactly how that works so
for a spec let's say it's a 250 million
dollar spec
the sponsor who's you know a chamath or
somebody in this case and he he's not
the only one reed hoffman's doing his
back a whole bunch of people are doing
them
uh they put down about three percent so
let's say 250 million dollar
spec
i don't do public math but i think
that's about eight million dollars that
they put in in their of their own
capital
and then when they
oh
everybody froze oh we're back okay
so you put you put three percent down
when you find a deal and you actually do
the deal you're going to get 20 of the
action so you're putting three percent
of the capital and you're going to get
20 of the of the deal so that's your
flip right there you put three percent
in you're going to own 20 by the end of
it um in addition to that there's things
called pipes pipe is basically oh i
raised 400 million but i need turns out
i found the company but i need 600
million to do the deal
so so before it goes public somebody can
come in and give you that that
difference that 200 million difference
you're short and they get a sweet deal
too because they're getting they know
the target they put the money in and
then very quickly it gets liquid for
them like you know because it go the
deal ends up you know in the public
markets then announced
so there's a lot of money to be made in
specs right now there's also a lot of
money to be lost if you're doing it
wrong if there's a lot of money i think
to make made there's a lot of money to
be made if you are
a certain couple people certainly by the
way is why it's so funny when people
like chemoth and i like tomorrow i think
he's great but i think he's a virtue
signaler like i think he uh he loves to
say the things that make him sound like
the people's you know the people robin
hood yeah i'm a robin that i'm saving
and everybody else is playing these
[__] games
why don't we do real hard work and solve
real problems and and cut out the
[__] he's all about that like those
rhetoric he's very good at those
speeches but if you look at what he did
it's like
dude you're you're playing the game just
as hard as anybody else in my opinion
you might believe you have better
intentions about why you're playing the
game but like let's be clear and i don't
have a lot of ins you're an insider and
you're an elite you're not the every man
everyday man that you're you're trying
he tries to kind of champion for but i
can't blame him like that's a good
strategy instead of saying i'm a rich
billionaire like with insider access you
know that doesn't play over so well and
i don't know if this is true today but i
think it was true i believe that his
spax chamas specs are like the an
aggregate of all across all of them like
the most shorted stocks on the stock
market
maybe they are now i i don't know i
haven't i haven't looked at that but
yeah definitely people have cooled off
on on some of the because if you look
eight what the thing is you look 18
months later
after they do their acquisition target
you're like how how are they doing so
like the typical spac curve was they
list at ten dollars
before they find a target they trade up
to 12 13 14 15 16 right so you're
getting this return before anything has
happened all right this is just like
greed and then they find the target and
then it either pops or it starts to
shrink depending on how people feel
about the target and then like 18 months
later
where where is that stock is it at 10 is
it above or is it below i think people
are doing some good analysis on this i'm
not super up to speed because i didn't
talk about specs today but
um
but anyways i think one example is uh
open door have you uh look at open doors
stock i think that's one of his specs uh
he's doing well now well i just look at
it it's the exact arc so you guys didn't
couldn't see this but right sean's uh
what what's that ark called it's just
like a like a like a standard deviation
cycle yeah like a no it was like a
standard deviation looking like a chart
and that's exactly what open door looks
like it's like starts small gets huge
goes back lists at 10
runs up to 34
and it's currently trading at 17 15 15
to 17. um and so you know
if you were in the ten dollar bucket
yeah you got it you gotta
you do have gains right now so i'm not
saying expects are good about i guess
what i'm saying is
if you're my my main theory here was you
got to do something different that's one
way if you found a different game now
people are going to copy you just like
they've written
to his credit
figured out that this is a good model
was the first one doing it and then
there's just been a flood of spac since
then everybody and their mom who can's
back wheels back right now and even
startups who can't really raise well or
don't aren't strong enough to go public
they can go public via a spec and then
all of a sudden hey we got liquid great
um so so there's definitely a lot of
like lipstick on the pig going on wait
so we have to wrap up this segment which
was vc you do the tiger thing you become
like chamath or do something different
and so those are one those are play a
different game tiger and spacking that's
an example of playing a different game
the second one is you're the big brand
so sequoia benchmark andreessen they're
always going to get the best deals or
they're going to get allocation if they
want in the best deals because of their
brand name and those funds are so big
and you can't even invest in them if you
wanted to if you're that seems like the
hardest one to do well yeah because okay
great it's like saying start off in
checkmate you know like how do i do that
how do i become that brand that's
obviously that takes time but they'll do
well i'm just talking about who's gonna
do well people playing a different game
then the big brands then the niche
specialist so this is like
i'm a vc fund focused on cannabis i'm a
vc fund focused on automation and
machine learning i'm a vc fund focused
on
let's call it sas software like david
sacks craft ventures so there's like a
whole bunch of these right vice ventures
there's they they brand themselves a
specialist in this one thing you could
do a media one if you wanted to and
basically what happens is if you picked
a vertical that works like sas is a good
vertical automation's a great vertical
right
um you're gonna see you're gonna see a
lot of you're gonna see more deals than
anybody else in that vertical than a
generalist because
you say no to everything else that's not
this so you're only spending your time
here
you build your brand there by creating a
bunch of content you're blogging you're
podcasting about why automation's the
future why self-driving cars are the
future blah blah blah so those founders
will come find you and then also you
they'll keep you in deals so even if
sequoia or benchmark wants to do a deal
the founder will add you for that
credibility because you're a specialist
in that niche and by you stamping them
it's valuable and they think you'll add
value because
you are more knowledgeable about this
domain than anybody else so i think
these specialists can do well then
there's celebrity angels that's like
naval biology same sort of thing as the
as the big brand
and then the last one is called venture
services
what are venture services
are you familiar with uh tusk tusk
ventures do you know what tusk
adventures is
no there's this guy this guy bradley
tusk he's got a book that you might have
read he was uh i think he's like a ex
washington policy guy i don't know
yeah know brad he's like a policy guy
what he got kind of known for was when
uber was uber was in its early stages
growing uber was having hella trouble
with cities
and the the taxi uh cartel and like
every every market they were fighting
against taxis in the cities and the
people wanted them there and so
they he was giving them a bunch of
consulting and advice and then he got to
invest and uber was like one of the best
investments of the decade for an angel
investor and he did that also with
airbnb another group that had policy
questions so any startup that had a
regulatory or policy challenge which
actually many do
uh it was like oh we should include tusk
in our round that's what their value add
is and so he had a services business
that was his consulting business for for
this that he built i think he owned a
hundred percent of it i think it's a
hundred million dollar business
and then he created a venture arm just
to invest equity and get equity and also
just exactly this yeah exactly the sort
of policy legal regulatory
lawyer basically
lawyer but specifically with like public
policy i think so like lawmakers more so
than like drafting your shareholder
agreements and so
you know built this really successful
services business but didn't leave it as
a service business added a venture arm
to it and because of that you owned
equity and things that ended up being
very very valuable and a lot of uh ad
agencies try doing this and they only do
okay they only do okay i think that if
you did it with a different a different
shtick like what this guy tusk was doing
then it could be interesting a lot of ad
agencies that do that like even you
remember red antler and all those guys
yeah
i think they took a sliver of equity you
you had to give them like
like there was a minimum it was like 50
grand plus some type of equity right
well friend of the pod andrew wilkinson
he was doing this with tiny right uh i'm
sorry with uh meta lab the design agency
so design agency and
so slack is paying them cash to design
the first slack client
could have took equity also or could
have had an equity arm that says great
let me also invest in your next round or
in this round with you
separately we'll take the cash on the
balance sheet that we're making from
consulting and we'll invest it into the
projects that we believe in that are in
in this portfolio would have done
phenomenally well but didn't do that in
his case um he used it to go buy
businesses separately did you hear do
you know who david cho is
no
so david cho and this will be the last
story david cho is this kind of
degenerate gambler crazy guy he's um
he when he was 18 he started traveling
he had a show when vice was popular of
him hitchhiking across the country it
was called like david cho hitchhikes
across the country and he's just kind of
this degenerate crazy person but he's an
artist and he's like a wonderful artist
a graffiti artist he's so good at it and
he's got some amazing work and
right when facebook got started david
cho was kind of like a cool guy uh like
a lot of people knew who he was and they
wanted his work but
uh you know he was hard to get so
eventually sean parker hires him to
paint facebook's office they want this
they want to paint this like amazing
graffiti and david cho goes uh yeah you
know be 50 grand and sean parker goes uh
well you want 50 grand in cash or 50
grand in facebook stock and he goes well
i'm a gambler give me the stock he takes
a stock and it's worth like 300 million
dollars uh a few years after facebook
goes ipo and it was all from this
facebook uh wall that he painted and i
went to the facebook office and they
ended up taking down the um
or they moved to a different office but
they saved the wall so throughout the
office you could still see the david cho
painting and so he ends up he at the
time when i wrote the article like four
years ago it was like 200 million
dollars that he made from the 50 000
worth of art now it's way more he's
actually on joe rogan all the time he's
a crazy guy this guy david cho is nice i
like it yeah basically
i think there's this model of venture
services which is
um
you know uh bobby goodlatte is doing
this with design uh bain did this back
in the day so you have bain and co the
consulting company and then bain capital
was their venture arm that they used so
i think that
investors who you can't just say you
know i'm good at this i'll give you
advice it's like i think there's going
to be investors that say
yeah use my like i have a company that
does this as an agency as a conservative
services company
and then we also invest and that
combination i think is gonna be pretty
powerful
[Music]
travel never looking back